now in addition to recording feedback on
what to improve we've been recording
feedback on what parts of our app really
resonate with users this feedback is
really vital to share in a presentation
on your prototype it will be one of your
greatest assets nothing shows that your
concept resonates with users quite like
hearing or seeing one of them be excited
when using your prototype because of
this it can be a good idea to get video
or audio recordings of your user testing
sessions the one rule is to always
always always get permission from your
subjects first we've said it before and
it's really vital that you do this ask
before you record and ask every user
what you need is a media release form
that covers research use and
presentation use this is a thing you
should look for online and then
customize and run by a lawyer before you
use it over the course of a few
iterations of user testing you should be
able to find some users who absolutely
adore your design if not you may need to
iterate more before you're ready to demo
your app